uy llevamos dos horas caminando por las
colinas del campus
forest
y la busque tropical
y ahora nos acercamos al jardín de este
león células salvajes wire garden hace
unos meses aquí es donde daniel salomón
agrónomo y un equipo de investigadores
de hugh gardens y la universidad de
greenwich hicieron un importante
descubrimiento cuidado no la rompas no
rompas te vale genial
este es un cafeto este no fila
este es uno de esos árboles ya están
dispersos por todo el bosque pero una
forma de reconocerlos es mirando la
punta de sus hojas
en el extremo
es muy puntiagudo y un poco curvado
así es como se ve la este no fila
cultivaba hasta principios del siglo 20
en áfrica occidental y especialmente
apreciado por los comerciantes europeos
el café este no fila se servía en las
mejores mesas de parís pero al ser
demasiado raro y caro fue sustituido
gradualmente por el arábica y el robusta
rechazado por los mercados olvidado por
los agricultores se cree que ha
desaparecido por completo desde 1954 de
2013 a 2018 buscamos y nos dimos cuenta
de que sólo crece a una altura de 400
metros sobre el nivel del mar
dije los equipos bueno tenemos las
colinas de campo y cerca de qué nema
porque no vamos a echar un vistazo
dijeron que sí así que llegamos a este
bosque subimos y finalmente vimos tres o
cuatro árboles el café se cultiva en
sierra leona desde hace décadas pero en
cantidades muy pequeñas el país lucha
por hacerse un hueco en el mercado
mundial solo es el decimonoveno
exportador de café de áfrica con el
redescubrimiento del este no fila las
esperanzas son altas
consciente de la ganancia financiera que
podría representar dentro de unos años
graham billington
un ex comerciante de diamantes que se ha
volcado en la exportación de café y
cacao ha invertido en una granja para
intentar reactivar el cultivo
este café es un tema candente en este
momento porque podría salvar la
producción mundial de café que está
colapsando con el calentamiento global
pero también porque tiene una verdadera
identidad un sabor único notas muy
interesantes así que obviamente por
muchas grandes compañías de café quieren
poner sus manos en un café tan raro y
único y único
las italianas y la baza o la suiza
nestlé ya han manifestado su interés
pero en que se benefician los
sierraleoneses en los límites de la
selva las comunidades que viven en
condiciones precarias temen que este
tesoro se les escape
estamos muy contentos por el
redescubrimiento de este café vale pero
viene de aquí de nuestros territorios
por lo que pedimos al gobierno que nos
permita participar en su desarrollo en
su cultura para que también podamos
aprovecharlo para vivir mejor
en sierra leona un pequeño caficultor
gana una media de 100 dólares al año por
ello las autoridades esperan que la
estén off y la abra un nuevo mercado
próspero y justo para sus agricultores